hey good afternoon everybody
um thank you for coming to javascript
for science uh before we begin our
presentation i want to emphasize that
although
we're going to be talking about
javascript and some web-based examples
today
that the stuff we're talking about in
this presentation is not specifically
isolated to javascript and
this particular language um so to begin
my name is angelina fabro i'm angelina
magnum on twitter
and i work for mozilla i work on firefox
os there but also i spend a lot of time
teaching people how to code
and before that i got a bachelor's
degree in cognitive science
and i worked in the software industry in
a variety of capacities
and i'm bill mills i'm a nuclear
physicist currently working for
triumph and at triumph i'm currently
responsible for the
user interface and user experience
design for the griffin collaboration
before that i spent a number of years
writing analysis software for the atlas
collaboration on the large hadron
collider at cern
all right so we're here to talk to you
guys today about a particular thing and
that thing
is that we would really really like you
to help us change the world and i know
that when people say that they you know
like you get this idea like okay one
person can't actually make a whole lot
of impact
but we've discovered a few things a few
patterns with the natural sciences in
particular and their programming
practices
that we think that the people in this
room probably have a lot to offer and
and help with that
and with your cooperation we can
actually do better science and thus that
does make the world a better place
so real talk so i want to start off with
a bit of a confession here a little bit
of real talk time
um
right uh so um so
um everyone here is familiar with
um uh with moore's law for
semiconductors and uh
integrated circuits it suggests that the
number of um
transistors on an integrated circuit
doubles every couple of years well
while i worked at cern i noticed a
similar phenomenon going on
with our detectors there and
what happened from that it can be
summarized here
what i have here is the number of data
collecting sensors per experiment
in cern's big flagship experiments over
the past
30 years so in the early 1980s we had an
experiment called ua1
and there was about maybe 10 000 data
collecting channels on ua1
fast forward to today in the atlas
experiment on the large hadron collider
and atlas has over a hundred million
data collecting
sensors the scale and complexity of
these experiments is skyrocketing it's
grown by
four orders of magnitude in only three
experimental iterations
and yet we haven't really kept up with
the
best practices from the software
engineering world and in so doing we've
amassed a tremendous technical debt
one thing that cern kind of got right
with these experiments
because they had to was that as their
experiments scaled up they developed
some tremendous data visualization
techniques i mean
as they were required to for an
experiment like atlas
so any member of the atlas collaboration
would recognize
this plot as having the fingerprints of
the higgs boson
in an event we recorded last year
and yet despite this leap forward in
experimental complexity
and despite our work in you know good
visualization for our experiments
in the five years that i wrote analysis
code for the atlas collaboration
i never received one single code review
at all the software meetings that i went
to every week for that
for that experiment words like uh
scalability portability maintainability
usability all the abilities of software
development weren't part of the
discussion
they just weren't on the radar of
scientists developing
there and there our technical debt began
to mount
as a result i believe that over time big
physics has a crew has
built some big monoliths of single-use
code
meanwhile uh while this was going on in
high energy physics in my other field
nuclear physics we built a web app
called midas that looks a little bit
like this
for monitoring and controlling our
experiments in
real time and one thing that i was
always really sort of
impressed with and proud of about midas
was that this was a web app built
in the mid 1990s i mean web app i don't
think web app was a word
in 1990 you know four or five when this
uh was first being developed but
nevertheless
businesses said you know this newfangled
internet thing
this is the way to bring our experiments
um
to make them more portable and more
usable into the future and so
we jumped on this bandwagon built midas
to great effect we've been using on many
experiments ever since
but that was 20 years ago now in the
intervening
two decades people that work on the on
the internet and develop web
technologies
have made brilliant beautiful advances
in
things like information design and
information architecture
usability and interactions and yet midas
is still exactly what it looks like it's
a table dump
of the thousands and thousands of
parameters
that go into a modern nuclear physics
experiment
we haven't integrated all those advances
yet
we're lagging behind there the gap
between
uh the natural sciences and uh software
engineering has grown
and our technical debt begins to mount
so bill and i met each other just a
little over two years ago i think we
established the other day and uh when we
met we
we realized that we had things that we
found very fascinating about the other
i mean i come from a software
engineering background in cognitive
science and bill comes from
a physics background with both nuclear
and particle physics
an area that i really did not know a lot
about and similarly bill did not know a
lot about what i was doing so
we ended up becoming friends and hanging
out and having conversations and
i remember the first day that this
discussion between us started i was
uh hanging out with bill and he said oh
hold on you know i've got to go do
something
i got to go jump into a terminal i got
to go look at some code i was like oh
cool you know
what are you working on and so i peer
over his shoulder
and i look at a file and i see that he's
online
thirteen thousand fifty thousand and
there's a big
mass there and and so i say hey bill um
are you really on line thirteen thousand
of fifty thousand
and like bill completely naive like
turns to me with these big
eyes like yeah why what's wrong with
that
and i'm like okay we've only been
friends for a really short while like i
don't know if this is the time to be
like all right serious time in our
friendship and relationship it's time to
talk about software development
practices
thankfully bill is an extremely
receptive individual so we obviously did
talk about those things
but the thing is really the point to be
made here is that bill just didn't know
better
when bill got into his phd he had maybe
uh
i think like one course in computing
science as an undergraduate
which is not sufficient knowledge and
expertise to build a system of the scale
that he was trying to build or the scale
of the simulation that he was working on
sometimes you just don't know any better
so now let's actually take a little bit
of a look of some of the examples of
things that we found an
actual production code from the domain
of physics
so i apologize if this is a little bit
small but we wanted to really capture
what's going on here
so the first thing you can note is that
there's this pyramid of doom
going on we've got like a really high
degree of nesting and usually code with
a lot of nesting like that
it's usually pretty bug prone because
it's very hard to keep a mental model of
what's going on with this kind of a
structure
the next thing that you'll note quite
generously there's one comment
and this is sort of an outlier the rest
of the examples there's no comments
and the thing is it's also really
ambiguous map the data from the jsonp
store okay i'm with you so far
to the dac object whatever that is
that's some domain knowledge thing
summing rates as we move upstream i
don't know what that stream is maybe
they mean as we move through the jsonp
file
i don't i don't know um and then of
course all of this is very terse
and i think what's going on right here
this dot data keys index of p
key equal to equal equal to negative one
i think that's
checking if something's out of bounds in
the array and
uh the person that wrote this code was
bill
so um so so this is an example of
something that like i'm pretty sure if
we spend some time with this code we
could refactor to be a lot more readable
a lot more maintainable
so the next example here uh is a bunch
of calculations across a number of axes
you've got a z variable an x variable a
y variable
but actually what i want to turn your
attention to is over on the right hand
side here this is from an editor in
sublime text
it does a really good job of giving you
sort of uh like a relative
idea of where you are in a file and how
long that file is
but it might be a little hard to see but
but there's actually a pattern here
you see this shape and then you see this
shape again and you see it again
and you see it again and can you guess
what's going on here
yeah that's right it's copy and paste
yeah so bill got this code and he was uh
someone else wrote it he was responsible
for refactoring it and this was done 16
times
so the person that wrote this code did
not maybe know
or did not understand that they could
take these calculations and put them in
a function and maybe call that function
16 times rather than copy and paste um
another few things another few things
about this is from talking to bill like
we know that these calculations are
calculating some points alone in axes
like z
x and y but there's no comments and even
though bill's refactoring this code
we have no idea what this is actually
calculating to be honest with you
we know that like good results come out
the other end of the code but
we actually don't know what this is
doing and this is often true for a lot
of inherited code and physics that you
that you know someone can be given like
you're given like a chunk of code yeah
so-and-so already did a simulation and
you get stuff like this
now the last example that i want to show
you is my favorite we've got that whole
thing that was going on with bill here i
think
i don't know what line we're on but
we're clearly at line 13 480 of some
file
and you'll notice at the top they're in
a file that's got a c
extension so it should be c but really
what we're looking at here is javascript
this is an
entire string in c that produces
javascript so the person that wrote this
knows javascript
because like when this spits out it runs
you know well properly
um but they chose to print it out as one
giant string in
c for reasons that are sort of unclear
but but not entirely i mean this person
was clearly
come the most comfortable in the domain
of c and probably c
plus and that's probably where they did
most of their uh simulations sorry one
of you in the audience has the most
horrified look on your face and i find
it hilarious
um that's the right reaction to this
stuff just like
i'm like whoa whoa i knew this was going
to be heavy but
um and so so you can see that you know
when you've got a hammer that's got the
label like c
or c plus on it everything starts to
look like a nail
you start trying to do things like put
the square peg in the round hole or just
circumvent the system entirely
altogether rather than learn the skills
that you need to adapt the environment
like maybe creating an interface in the
web browser
so this you know this is not really what
you want to be doing
and so we've discovered from talking to
our peers in the scientific community
and like you know i have other friends
than the bill that have gone through
grad school in other areas like ecology
and you know even in engineering and uh
it seems to me that there's an impetus
to write on maintainable code
so imagine that you're a grad student
and you're trying to get yourself
towards the end of your phd
you probably think that you know you're
writing this code you're going to write
it once just to prove the results of
your
of your theory and your calculations
and that probably no one's ever going to
use it again but that's often not the
case these grad students will go on and
graduate probably they'll go to a
postdoc or something else at another
school
but their supervisor will know about
that code their supervisor
hasn't vetted that code and when someone
new comes that is maybe in the same area
of research they say
okay you know so and so bill was here uh
you can use his code and here's a
starting point
and this is really dangerous because
that person is given a big big piece of
like tightly coupled monolithic code
and it may you know it may inspire them
towards really
you know problematic development
practices and perpetuate the cycle
another situation is that when you're in
the academic world there's a whole lot
of pressure to publish against
deadlines uh whether it be for a
conference or just for a paper and a
publication
i mean that's what happens in the
software industry as well i mean
sometimes you know your boss says okay
you've got to stay late on friday night
and we really need to ship this this
iteration of our product
and you know when you're under that time
pressure and you want to have time what
do you do
like you don't write the best possible
quote that you know how to write you
get in a hack so that it's fixed on
production the same is true for for this
code in physics
when they need to publish a paper when
you need to publish a paper or be ready
for a conference
um you just get it out the door so you
can say that your your simulation works
and the problem is when you create
software this way when you just keep
adding hacks you don't comment and you
create these tightly coupled
monolithic pieces of software
refactoring ends up feeling a little bit
like this
um you know you don't have the expertise
to go through a big piece of code
and you just kind of cut and paste and
move things around and nested
nothingness and then once it works
you were so frustrated to begin with you
just you just don't touch it
but the good news is not all lab science
the same there are a few labs out there
that actually
do understand that we do need
maintainable software
and we do need good tools for scientists
to
write you know like have maintainable
experiments and and do good science
so for the past year now i've had the
privilege of working for the griffin
experiment at
triumph and the griffin experiment is a
new
gamma-ray spectroscopy experiment uh
totally cutting edge and
head of its field coming online at
triumph next year
griffin's physics goals are threefold
first we will be
exploring the r process which is how the
heaviest elements get made
in supernovae we will be
examining fundamental physical
symmetries as a cross-check mechanism
for high-energy experiments going on at
labs like cern
and also we'll be continuing triumph's
long-standing tradition of contributing
to
the study of nuclear structure with this
array of
gamma-ray detectors and their auxiliary
apparatus in addition to
our physics goals we have a number of
computing goals for griffin as well
first and foremost of them is that both
i and the management of this experiment
see griffin as an opportunity to take a
step forward
uh in terms of how physicists interact
with their code
and how they build user interface and
user experience
um machinery for for interacting with
their experiments
so over the past year i have been
developing a web app to
meet this goal with the goals of making
an interface for griffin
that requires as little domain knowledge
as possible
see there's going to be groups of
scientists coming through triumph every
week or two weeks to use this apparatus
they cannot spend a long time
uh learning how to use this thing so we
want to use the best of web technology
and
and interaction design to make this as
simple as possible
so i'm going to walk you through a few
of the features that i produced for
triumph
and while i do so i want you to keep in
mind two things first of all
how we solved these problems before was
via that table dump that i showed you so
contrast this to having everything just
in a bunch of numbers in a list
and the second thing is i want you to be
absolutely brutal and critical
think about how you would have solved
these problems think about how
uh or what you think is still lacking
with the solutions that i've come up
with because i mean
i'm a physicist just kind of swan diving
into user experience design
i'm sure experts and professionals would
have even more to say
about these ideas so let's dive in here
here is my web app and it serves a whole
bunch of different purposes
for griffin one of the main assets that
it produces is the skeuomorphic
representations of our detectors that
let us see
what these detectors are doing in real
time at a glance
it also provides a high density view of
our high voltage information
that allows us to monitor the many
hundreds of high voltage channels we
need to run these apparatus all at a
glance
so that we can see sort of easily notice
when one of these channels might be
going wrong like we have over here
we needed a data throughput monitor
which i have here so these are like my
my data collecting nodes and it shows
how much data is getting pushed up to my
master here so we can keep track of how
much we're writing to disk all at once
we've got a bunch of hardware monitoring
assets for our atomic clocks and our
voltage crates
and a bunch of interaction design
objects which i'll take you through in
more detail
later this is like the purpose of this
is to like i said
monitor in real time for the sake of
debugging and troubleshooting everything
that's going on in this experiment
and so like i said i'll go back to these
skeumorphic detector representations
here
and so what we're looking at here is uh
duscant and duscont is
a collection of sensors it's a big round
thing actually which is why this is
round here and uh it detects um
neutrons uh neutrons firing pardon me
and so there are about 70
yeah there's 70 uh detectors or sensors
here
and at the bottom here we've got a scale
that shows from zero to one
kilohertz there yeah so all of the
colors that are sort of like the warm
range are firing between like 0.3 and
0.6 which is about 300 to 600
events per second now as bill was saying
before this information basically came
in a giant
like table that was a data dump so if
something ever went wrong with these
detectors
uh you would you know look in that table
and you would of course find probably a
zero
but the difficult thing with those table
dumps is the information was not always
necessarily organized
in a way where all of those zeroes might
come together as a clump
you would have to have domain knowledge
to know to look to that table
to see the zeros and then you have to go
through the table find all the zeros and
figure out
what that meant for where those were in
the detector like
which sensors were actually
malfunctioning by creating the
skeuomorphic representation of the
detector we can easily see at a glance
where the zeros are
and that this portion of the detector
actually has a problem now
the interesting thing about this is that
the context preserves a lot of
information it makes it a lot easier to
see what the problem is at a glance
now what i find fascinating about bill's
implementation here is
one day he came to me and he said
angelina can you help me debug my
javascript and i'd been teaching build
javascript before he had this job and i
was like of course sure
i will totally help you debug your
javascript and so i hadn't really
played too much with his web app i left
him to his own devices and i
uh you know right clicked on something
that i thought was going to be a dom
element and went to go inspect it in the
browser
and instead i found that bill had done
everything with like three canvases
so where i was expecting a bunch of dom
elements actually bill
had used a bunch of canvases and i asked
him i was like well you know i know you
understand the box model i know you
understand
html and css and javascript why did you
do everything in canvas
and the answer was very simple well you
know i was under some time pressures and
i just wanted to get something made
and i just didn't know how to make a
hexagonal div
i was like okay that seems reasonable um
and
uh and so he you know he discovered the
canvas object
and that he could control every pixel
written to the screen or in that canvas
object and that he could actually draw
out the skeuomorphic representation and
also deal with uh the changing state of
the experiment in a really elegant way
and on top of that you know so he
implemented this in canvas but he also
went on to implement his own
uh event listeners and also his own uh
tool tips as well
which on one hand i found totally
ridiculous and on the other hand i also
found totally amazing that like i just
kind of left him alone and this is what
he did
but this is a bit serendipitous right
like on one hand we can know know
in a situation that like if we leave
someone to the devices it might not turn
out terribly well
in bill's case uh with the number of
elements that he needs to represent
and their changing state doing this in
canvas probably in the end ends up being
more performant than juggling a bunch of
dom elements and dealing with their
state
so so for bill's purposes this ends up
being actually probably the better
solution
but you can imagine how like this could
have gone sideways where another
situation or another technology or
somebody just fumbling around and hoping
to get it right
um and so the interesting thing um in
addition to that
is let me pop over here to shark
we're dealing with so many channels of
information now this is an exploded view
of another detector of course it's got
the same sort of firing rate
representation
but actually these panels are uh
averages
of detectors within them so we've got
kind of like this long box-like thing
and then on the ends there's like these
circular things which is really
the technical way to explain it but if
you actually click
and drill down you can see that there is
actually even more detectors in there
so bill has done an excellent job here
of creating representation so that
scientists can get exactly the
information that they want and
knowing exactly what component in the
experiment is producing that information
without having to fumble with some
sort of table
okay so as angelina has walked through
here there's a whole lot of uh
information design problems we had to
address uh in griffin
and i mean there's still plenty more
right i mean doing a 70 channel detector
like descant like this was sort of no
big deal
when you move to something as complex as
shark i mean it's it's kind of tough to
tell what's going on here
someone with real experience in user
interface design could do even better
here
but anyway it's not just ui and ux
problems that
we have to deal with we also have a lot
of interaction problems to solve
so in any one of these experiments you
always have to set up
a simple experimental cycle that you're
going to run through while your
experiment runs
so how these experiments are typically
configured is there'll be a big
spherical array of detectors arranged
around a point where you're going to
want to have your source and how you put
your source in the middle of those
detectors is there's like a movie reel
like a movie tape
that you can move into place in the
middle of your detectors then you turn
your radioactive beam on and you implant
a bunch of
you know radioactive goop on that movie
tape then you turn your sensors on and
record data and you repeat that cycle
you know a million times for as long as
you want to collect data for
simple enough but before i developed
this web app
uh what you had to do to implement
something like that is that each of
those actions
would have like a little bit pattern and
then by hand for some reason
uh you had to take those bit patterns
and add them together turn it into a hex
number
take that hex number and put it in that
table
that big table dump of of instructions
that run this experiment
now i mean i suppose that's not very
complicated or very hard which is why it
survived for so long but it's also
completely unnecessary
there are so many good tools for
interacting with a
with a piece of software that being
stuck in the in the 1960s like that just
seems a little silly
so i mean what i developed to solve that
i can re-implement
the exact cycle i just described with
this interface i can clear my memory
there we go and i'll move my tape into
place and then maybe i'll implant some
radioactive source on my tape and then
i'll turn my detectors on
there we go i've made an i made an
experimental cycle for griffin it took
like 10 seconds
and all i had to do was use my intuitive
notion of
interactions that i've got from just you
know general fluency with
computers and smartphones and stuff no
special domain knowledge is required
anymore
that's one of the main goals for
interface design
in the sciences is to suppress that
domain knowledge put as much of it in
the background as possible
so we don't get distracted by it because
that's what domain knowledge ends up
being particularly for new collaborators
is a distraction that stops us from
making more progress in the sciences
all right so i'm going to talk a little
bit about the sort of cognitive biases
that really get us in the way of
ourselves and the way of achieving
things
so in 2012 i organized the vancouver
chapter of the
international space apps challenge and
so for the international space apps
challenge what nasa did was they said
we want to engage people who are not
necessarily professional scientists we
want people from interaction design
user experience design we want software
developers we want to get them together
for this weekend codeathon or hackathon
and we will pose a number of challenges
for them to solve
and then we would like to see the best
solutions you know the winners of each
one that
you know the judges thought were the
best and uh and then they you know they
would go on to sort of like an
international level of voting and
uh projects that were particularly
interesting and caught the eye of nasa
and they were released open source nasa
would then sort of like draw
either inspiration or use their code and
that happened in a number of instances
so in the vancouver location um we had a
fairly reasonable turnout for like a
code-a-thon hackathon kind of event
it was definitely skewed like the the
attendees are definitely
more skewed towards like academia like
we got a lot of people in computing
science and
uh disappointing for me not as many
people from the software industry
um one of the groups that one did a
really fantastic uh sorry the group that
one did a really fantastic
visualization of the aurora borealis in
real time using like a data feed from
nasa
and it was fantastic and when they were
talking to me they said
oh yeah you know last night i was
talking to my friends and they were
asking me all these questions about what
we were doing at the nasa space apps
challenge
i said oh what do your friends do
they're professional software developers
i'm like okay well
why didn't they come oh well when they
heard it was going to be science they
thought that they didn't have the
necessary skills or knowledge to
participate
and that was just really disappointing
for me because
even if you don't have the necessary
domain knowledge for physics that
doesn't mean that you can't
learn a little bit and it doesn't mean
that you can't contribute even if you
don't have specific domain knowledge
like bill does about all of these
detectors
i mean i obviously have a cursory
understanding now which which helps me
help bill
but you can still go through those code
examples earlier and see like that
there's obvious problems to be solved
so uh and then from the other end of
things uh often in physics
physicists or physicists and other
scientists can be very very resistant to
asking for outside help like when it
comes to things like third-party
libraries
um physicists like to have a lot of
control over the things that they're
doing
which is sort of why bill found the
canvas element and thought that was like
you know his sort of silver bullet
and the idea behind this is even if
they're building a big monolithic
unmaintainable piece of software
at least they know everything about it
so the idea of going to an open source
project
uh you know or or an established
solution for databases like you know
mysql or mongodb or something that in
the industry we would know is tried and
tested
uh the physicist or or other natural
scientist may have the impetus to be
like
well i don't want to put it in my code
if i don't understand everything about
it
so even suggesting like hey you're
building a web app why don't you use
like a selector library or why don't you
use
uh you know this this bit of niceness
they don't want to put it in their code
sometimes unless they can read through
every line
and and uh you know know how it works
and so they'll just avoid it and try
building their own thing
and i think it was bill that was telling
me about a particular instance in a
physics library where they had
decided not to use like a
production-ready database that we would
use in the industry but they'd
actually re-implemented their own
version of odbc
which was terrible so they're kind of
like repeating effort because uh there's
like this
this fear of uh taking up too much time
understanding these uh extra pieces
uh and it leads to to this i mean i
think that a lot of people that go
through their their phd and are in the
sciences end up kind of burnt out on a
lot of this code stuff because
they don't have any help and they don't
actually know any better and
really this is sort of contrary to the
idea that science should always be a
collaboration so why aren't software
developers collaborating with scientists
we've got this sort of barrier this idea
that
because we're not professional
scientists or maybe you know i'm a
software world because i'm not a
professional scientist
i can't contribute to science that's
patently false
and physicists and other natural
scientists that are you know
coding and learning to code should
probably be teaming up with people on
software so they can solve these
problems more
efficiently and do better science so the
question really is how do we adapt our
culture to do this with these
these sort of like cognitive biases in
play
this problem has to be approached from
both sides of the equation
actually and one of the most important
things is
for programmers is what angelina has
already touched on and that's that
uh the lack of domain knowledge in the
science of your choice whatever
interests you the most
does not matter at all we've got plenty
of physicists to handle that
and as you can see i mean angelina just
from some cursory conversations with me
picked up everything she needed to know
about the griffin experiment and its
auxiliary detectors
to be able to afford me the advice i
needed
working on this project we showed you
started off by showing you those code
examples and those uh
user interface and user experience uh
design examples
uh to emphasize the fact that really
what
often needs help with is things that are
very familiar to you and it's the domain
knowledge
not here but out there in this audience
and in the software
uh engineering field that's really uh
really at a loss for and we really need
uh to bring in
[Music]
so one of the most important things you
can do with your colleagues and friends
and
contacts in the sciences is educate them
on the value of
open sourcing their code there's very
little anyone outside the field can do
for scientists as long as their code
remains locked up in a black box
somewhere
on top of this encourage them to
consider the fact that
while they hold peer review very dear to
their hearts
when the overwhelming majority of their
results comes from code that no one can
see what does peer review really mean
at that point we need to start making
science more open
so that we can collaborate effectively
on it
if you want to get a little more
involved this is sort of like a grading
scale
of involvement and engagement the next
step would be code reviews
have a look once you get your scientist
friends to open source their code have a
look at it
see if you can spot any any
anti-patterns in it because as you can
see from the code examples we started
with
some of them are going to be really
obvious and really simple uh for
uh for professional software developers
it would be just a few minutes to look
at that and say hey
have you ever thought of a for loop or
have you ever thought of factoring that
into a function
and it would make a dramatic improvement
in this code
uh one step up from that as well would
be make a pull request refactor a little
bit of the code to do
things in a way that makes a lot more
sense from a good engineering
perspective
i mean we don't expect you to solve our
whole technical debt for us that's silly
but one tiny example that we can learn
from and take away
can make a tremendous difference
particularly in the life of a student
someone who's just learning just in grad
school now learning
how to code how to deal with these giant
frameworks of infrastructure
uh if they learn this early just with a
tiny example
uh they'll take that away for the rest
of their careers and that effect
ripples outwards um as you could see
from my uh
experiences in ui design as i mentioned
earlier i mean i have no training in
user experience obviously
normally when i interact with it it
feels a little bit like this
uh i tried my best but i'm sure there's
people out here that have even better
ideas than i did on how to make
physics experiments or experiments in
any field as interactable as possible
with a minimum of domain knowledge
another element that we could use help
with isn't just in software but in our
hardware infrastructure
so another uh sort of cutting edge
element of griffin
is that griffin will write 200 terabytes
of data to disk
every single week and we'd like to
analyze that
in a day now that's not an
insurmountable problem
but it's an ongoing discussion right now
of exactly how we're going to build
a cluster to do that and uh for some
people i mean this might be a problem
you've engaged with before
you might have some useful advice for us
i'd say we would love to
hear your expertise on these matters so
a message for scientists out there i
mean i know
that i know that earlier like you you
know if this is being recorded if you
heard the audience like giggle a little
bit
uh at the code they're like we're not
showing you this and we're not pointing
this out to shame anybody because
frankly
at some point when i was learning
software development and learning
programming uh years ago
i wrote code like that and obviously the
first example i showed you is code that
bill wrote and bill definitely writes
better code now so just to be clear like
there's this
isn't you know to shame anybody we just
want you to do better and
uh just understand that if you're not a
software engineer then you are out of
your domain
and you probably need to be accepting
help or looking for advice
as bill mentioned and we really want to
stress this get your code in the open
so much code is written for these
experiments these simulations to verify
results and it literally is a black box
people will submit these papers for
research uh for publication
and go to conferences and do poster
presentations but they don't show the
code with it
nobody looks at the code the supervisor
involved as long as the code at the end
spits out kind of the right looking
example kind of in the right looking
range
we just assume that it's okay and that's
a little bit of a problem i think
getting your code in the open really
really makes this a collaborative
process and it really makes science as
open as it should be
so bring software developers and
computing scientists on board and
preferably bring them on board early
because uh it will sort of have like a
ripple or a butterfly effect if you help
if you get some really good advice on
making design decisions with how you do
your software early on
and you can carry that through your
project and i mean if you're in a
situation at a lab where you're you know
you can't bring them on early bring them
on to help you manage the technical that
you that you have that's better than not
bringing them in
at all so then the other one is like i
was saying we're not trying to shame
anybody just be okay with the fact that
sometimes you write crap code
i know that when i'm prototyping
something like i'm prototyping a feature
i'll just be completely messy with it
i'll be like you know what i'm gonna
nest this like six times and i'm just
gonna kind of get a result
and then like two days day two days
later i go back to i'm like what idiot
wrote this
and i iterate on it and i make it better
and one of the things i want to mention
here is that over in the industry we've
sort of like you know
got this dichotomy of waterfall design
versus iterative
design or waterfall development versus
iterative development
and that's that you know in waterfall
development you like plan everything
linearly and you sort of expect that
everything's totally going to go
smoothly you're not going to hit any
roadblocks and thus you'll end up with a
perfect solution at the end
in reality this pretty much never
happens so i mean once you do get
something
working uh sort of you need to be aware
of the fact that probably your code
isn't going to go into a vacuum
somewhere even if you are reasonably
certain it is because your supervisor
might hand it off to somewhere else
to someone else and uh that you know
once you've written it just go back to
it and iterate on it and
and try and make it better don't don't
fall a victim to the notion that you
know you writing it once is going to be
enough for you that's just not how good
software is written
if you're a writer and you're writing a
novel you don't just go like okay first
draft
going to send it off to the publisher
guess that'll be okay
no no the editor will help you iterate
on the process
and then your book will be published the
same can definitely be true for software
because we like to pretend we all know
what we're doing when we're writing
software but really a lot of us just
fumble around kind of like this cat
so one particular philosophy i think
that could really really benefit
scientists out there especially when
people are learning to code is test
driven development or behavior driven
development
which if you're unfamiliar with it it
basically means that before you write
your main piece of software
you get a testing suite and there's some
available for all sorts of different
languages
and you write your tests first and you
describe the behavior that you want with
your tests
and then you write the software so that
those tests pass and this has a
effect in two ways one if somebody is
unfamiliar with how to write really good
software
you've kind of given them an itemized
list of the things that they need to
achieve you've kind of said okay if
you're going to write software to
support the simulation
then here's the things that you need to
do in order for things to
to be complete the other thing that
happens is when you do this it sort of
forces you to write really modular and
decoupled code
when you're testing very small pieces of
of
features or testing really really small
pieces of a library
your code by nature has to become more
modular and more modular code is
definitely more maintainable over time
so just to wrap up here
before i came to strange loop i talked
to a lot of different scientists not
just physicists because it's not just
physicists that have this problem
i spoke to agricultural scientists and
ecologists and
life scientists as many people as i
could speak to
and the story was the same from every
different field that i encountered
but the one anecdote that i wanted to
share that was the most important was
the one
from the ecologist that i spoke to i
asked the ecologist
what would you do with more computing
expertise on your team
and the ecologist said to me the most
useful thing that a software developer
could do for me today
would be just to sit down with me and
have a conversation
explain to me exactly what uh
software engineering can do for me our
fields have split
so much software engineering has
diverged so far
from so many of the natural sciences
sciences that professionals in the field
don't even know what to ask for at this
point and that technical debt
that ultimate cost of the extreme
example of reductionism that we've
gotten into
is starting to seriously hamper our
efforts to advance our sciences
we've gone very very far in our little
boxes
but now there's a tremendous amount of
low-hanging fruit
in the overlaps between our fields if we
want to start moving forward quickly
again
those are the places we have to look for
so when alex miller invited me to speak
at strange loop i actually
had not heard of strangeloop before and
i thought that was a bit surprising
because i speak at a lot of technical
conferences but
of course i you know typed it into my
you know generic search engine
and i looked up strange loop and i saw
some of the talks from last year and it
was immediately apparent to me what an
interdisciplinary conference this was
like there's clearly a lot of people
here from academic computing
there's a lot of people here from the
software industry and i knew that this
was the talk that i wanted to give and i
encouraged alex like come on i got to
bring dr mills with me because we've
been working on this for a while and we
really think that this is
obviously really important to help
better mankind and help uh you know
actually produce
better science with with reliable
results um
so i was really really glad that i could
come here today and share this with this
particular audience because i think that
you guys
uh may be probably the most receptive to
this idea
um so i mean things are changing uh a
project actually cropped up uh where at
cern right now a bunch of
professional web developers there's
actually some friends of mine there
brian leroux and remy sharp and
not pictured there's a really awesome
developer that i look up to named leah
veru
and they were actually brought into cern
to help recreate the original line
browser for the web
and although this isn't cern importing
people to necessarily work on a physics
experiment
they did go out of their way to say okay
we want to recreate this important piece
of web history
let's get people who are professionals
to do it and that's something i hope
that we see with labs and attitude more
and more
so this website
interdisciplinaryprogramming.com
tell your friends if you go there right
now there's a very very simple
web form um if you sign up at the web
form
all that happens is we're going to hold
on to your email and we're going to hold
into little information about like how
many people are scientists how many
people are software developers
and what bill and i are working on is a
platform to connect people in the
sciences
and connect people in software
engineering and computing science
together
so that in the future you know if you're
interested in helping science you can
like go to that website and be like you
know what i
want to work with someone doing like
quantum physics experiments oh look
there's a lab that might be receptive to
me helping the idea being that we're
kind of doing like a
matchmaking service for both sides so
that we can bridge this gap and that
project will be launching in 2014.
so please take this domain and tell your
friends tweet about it if you know
people that are in grad school
or working in an academic field please
tell them about it we would love to hear
from them especially about their
experiences and the kinds of things that
they would need
from a web platform like this so
in conclusion thank you strange loop for
having us here to sort of spread this
message
you can find me as angelina angelina
magnum on twitter and
bill is bill does physics because that
what he does and the slides will be
tweeted afterwards if you are interested
thanks everyone